bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors voilà les taux qui se
desserre donc aujourd'hui aux frontières
avec les voyageurs arrivant des états
unis et de l'union européenne qui n'ont
plus besoin de passer une quarantaine
une mesure qui ne concerne pas la france
paris juge cette décision
incompréhensible et discriminatoire est
ce que vous comprenez justement là la
colère du secrétaire d'état français par
rapport à la décision britannique
je comprends qu'il y a que cela déplait
fortement et t elle entendue c'était il
n'ya pas que lui qui concerné par la
situation et de nombreux britanniques
qui habite en france sont consommés
aussi et puis des voyageurs qu'un
français qui voudraient voyage et aux
amis dans beaucoup de monde est concerné
et il ya certainement un souhait très
largement partagée de voir cette
restriction levée prochainement
j'ai entendu de 2,2 d'amis actifs ton
avis politique que les chances d'une à
innover tout à fait prochaine de la
restriction son sang sont très bons mais
je ne peux pas vous en dire plus mais
bien sûr il y a une âme
c'est cet enjeu pour la france et pour
les responsables de français politiques
de se trouver face à cette restriction
alors la mesure donc est justifiée par
les autorités britanniques à part la
crainte du variant sud-africain bêta on
sait qu'aujourd'hui en france c'est
plutôt le variant delta qui est
majoritaire qui représentent plus de 90%
des décontaminations donc on se pose la
question est ce que finalement cette
décision est une décision salutaire ou
politique de la part des autorités
britanniques
je ne peux pas répondre à leurs classes
il est vrai que
depuis un an peut-être il ya des
tensions parfois sur des questions un
peu secondaire parfois sur les questions
prix majeurs entre la la france et de
leroy et mener la france a été
particulièrement agressive on pourrait
dire dans les négociations sur l'accord
sur le retrait du royaume uni ce qui est
beaucoup plus j'apprécie que l'allemagne
par exemple
et est-ce que ce contexte de friction
diverses et variées concernant la pêche
par exemple la france était très en
pointe dans les critiques doit muni
concernant les rangs du nord alors il ya
un véritable problème pratique que le
mouvement politique se doit de traiter à
est ce que ces frictions contribuer je
ne peux pas l'affirmer mais je pense que
sur le fond les sur les vraiment grands
sujets la france et le royaume uni ce
travail un ensemble sur les questions de
renseignement de défense à mais les
grands sujets de politique
internationale donc
donc si il peut y avoir une dimension
politique
je pense qu'elle serait pas s'ingérer
guiscard est très rapide en somme à
l'appréciation personnelle je vous livre
là alors dernière question c'est que le
royaume uni a été gravement touché par
la pandémie
que le pays aussi connaît actuellement
une nouvelle vague épidémique est
cependant on sait que les autorités bien
ont décidé de lever les restrictions
après le freedom day donc la levée
totale des restrictions aujourd'hui
cette levée voilà des mesures notamment
aux frontières
et n'est ce pas là un paradoxe entre
justement la situation sanitaire et les
décisions qui sont prises à par les
autorités ça peut paraître paradoxal
maintenant c'est tout à fait c'est tout
à fait logique
la famille était très bon devant toucher
le premier ministre lui même a été
hospitalisé au spécialiste de ces
questions est il assez gras pendant
quelques jours donc il ya une grande
sensibilisation ou dont j'ai besoin de
la pandémie
cependant vous l'avez dit le taux de
vaccination en classe ce même au dessous
de 70 % aujourd'hui et le nombre de
nouvelles infections est en baisse et se
trouve à un niveau relativement
relativement bas et on considère aussi
que le christ delà du nombre de
personnes action il ya une autre facteur
qui contribue à l'immunité collective à
savoir juste le nombre de personnes qui
ont déjà été infectées dont il ya une
logique scientifique derrière certains
cette politique et donc elle n'a rien
d'arbitraire ou de d'y réfléchir
merci beaucoup en tout cas paul thompson
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes vice-président du
parti conservateur britannique en france